French president Emmanuel macron says he
thinks President Trump will back out of
the Iran nuclear deal in the next two
weeks McCrone kept a three-day state
visit with an address to a joint meeting
of Congress where he urged the u.s. not
to abandon this deal he offered a sharp
contrast to president Trump's
america-first policy saying the US needs
to engage other countries and avoid
isolationism and nationalism
Face the Nation moderator and CBS News
senior foreign affairs correspondent
Margaret Brennan was one of the few
reporters to meet with micron yesterday
she's with us now from Washington
Margaret good morning the French
president says he thinks that President
Trump will almost certainly trigger a
period period of middle tension in the
Middle East if he withdraws from the
Iran deal so what could happen if the
President does not recertify well this
is a deadline of May 12th and president
Matt Crone believes that President Trump
will withdraw that'll spike tension and
a lot of this depends reaction wise on
how Iran particularly their hardliners
respond remember many were already
skeptical of making any deal with
America and if the u.s. breaks its
commitment it could have consequences
including restarting Iran's nuclear
development president Trump warned he
would respond to that
there are a number of potential flash
points in the next month there are u.s.
troops in close proximity in Syria and
Iraq to Iranian forces there also four
Americans still behind bars in Iran
whose fate may be in jeopardy but the
big gamble here for president Trump is
that using this tension and pressure
could lead to a new kind of diplomatic
breakthrough and it's one that the
French president says he wants to lead
of course the Europeans are worried that
if the president's gambling he's kind of
gambling with their money too so Angela
Merkel is coming from Germany next week
is she part of a coordinated effort here
to try to keep the president from going
this way on Iran absolutely she is you
know the leader of Germany it is the
engine of Europe but unfortunately she
doesn't have that warm rapport with
President Trump that the French
president does they've made clear
neither Merkel nor Trump really care for
each other here but she is someone to be
reckoned with in terms of leadership
in Europe she's going to argue a deal is
a deal America must abide by its
commitment here and trying to rewrite
rules we'll throw into jeopardy all the
other commitments that America has made
but if anyone believes that they can
succeed with President Trump in
persuading both Iran and the u.s. choose
cool tensions and engage in a new round
of diplomacy it is more likely to be
France as macron Germany's miracle of
course is key to any kind of
communication with Russia's Vladimir
Putin and very quickly Margaret there
was a difference between Matt crawling
in public with the president and then
what he said in front of Congress what's
the balance in terms of their
relationship after this trip well there
was some criticism wrapped in this
veneer of flattery from the French
president the address he gave to
Congress was very well received and he
championed a lot of traditional American
values he talked about the u.s.
upholding its commitments to NATO to the
UN the global order that America helped
build after World War two all those
things that sometimes seem at odds with
trumpism so it's not clear if that warm
relationship will translate into
changing the president's mind on any of
the issues on which they disagree all
right Margaret thanks we'll look forward
to Face the Nation Sunday morning as we
always do right here on CBS